What does the catalyst
speeds up the reaction and what,
what makes it a catalyst?
Yeah.
So it,
it speeds up the reaction and itself is not consumed in the reaction.
There are all sorts of things you can add to a reaction to make it go faster.
But unless you can get it back or unless it's regenerated in the process,
it's not a catalyst.
Um,
and so we
typically think of,
you know,
chemical reactions.
You have molecules that are kind of just bouncing around and the,
you know,
whether there's a reaction or not,
you have molecules,
they're moving around,
they're hitting each other,
they're hitting into the walls of whatever flasks,
clarion,
and it's just kind of this random mosh pit.
And for you to have a reaction,
you need to have molecules hit and exactly the right way.
Uh,
and you know,
they're bumping into each other all the time.
Say there's a one in a million chance that two molecules will hit just the right
way.
That's actually really good odds because molecules are bumping into each other
about a billion times a second.
So that react about a million times per second if it's one in a million chance.
Um,
so in reality,
you know,
the chance of having a productive reaction when the molecules bump into each
other,
it's way less than one in a million
catalysts.
Uh,
well,
so before catalysts you can increase the rate of a reaction by heating it.
Basically all that does is it makes the molecules move faster.
So they bumped into each other more often and they bumped into each other
harder.
Um,
so this can speed up the reaction rate just by having them interact more
frequently.
Or there are some reactions where you need,
there's a certain amount of energy required.
You know,
you have to break a bond first and that takes energy.
And so you need the molecules to hate each other hard enough.
So if it's room temperature,
there might be a reaction that would take 20 million years to,
to reach completion.
But if you heat it up to 120 degrees,
it's duck.
And that's just because the molecules are hitting each other hard enough that
they can actually do the chemistry that's involved
soft.
So
what do catalysts do?
They can do multiple things,
but I'm going to break it down into basically two tasks that a catalyst can do.
And some Kevin catalysts do only one and some do both.
They can increase the frequency that molecules interact.
So a lot of what enzymes do in your body is rather than just waiting around for
molecules to hit each other randomly,
the catalyst will actually collect the different reactive molecules and bring
them together and put them in the right position so they can react and go on.
And this can actually increase the reaction rate,
you know,
a million fold easily just by getting molecules in the right place at the right
time.
This is especially true,
you know,
most reactions are just two molecules hate each other.
There are some reactions that require three or four molecules to be in exactly
the right arrangement.
And if you think about the statistics of that happening randomly,
the chances are essentially nil that you're going to get four molecules in
exactly the right place and position at the right time unless you have something
that's bringing them and putting them all in the right place at the right time,
getting the reaction to happen,
and then kicking out the product ready to start again.
So catalysts can also increase reaction rate by,
um,
yeah,
even if the molecules are just randomly bumping into each other,
if they either don't have the energy or there's just some,
you know,
reactions are moving bonds and atoms and electrons around.
And if things are just left to chance,
sometimes they don't end up in the right place or you know,
it just,
it doesn't necessarily work out.
Right.
So a catalyst can also just,
you know,
given that two molecules interact,
the catalysts can increase the probability that that reaction happens.
So if you can change your million one in a million chances of every collision,
you can change that to every time the molecules come into contact,
there's a 50,
50 chance that they do the reaction.
Your reaction is going to go way,
way faster.
So I have,
before I talk too much more about Ketalysis,
I want to have some demonstrations.
So you have kind of an idea about what we're talking about.
Um,
just some flasks.
There's a little bit of water in the bottom of this one.
I watched them last night,
didn't have time to try.
Um,
but so I'm doing actually,
yeah.
Yeah.
Okay.
So the reaction that I'm going to be doing,
decomposition of hydrogen peroxide to water
oxygen
can also draw this out.
So hydrogen peroxide,
this molecule here,
oxygen,
oxygen bond is very weak.
Oxygen is very electronegative.
It really wants electrons and it doesn't like sharing when it's bonded to oxygen
has to share.
And so this bond is really weak.
Now,
molecular oxygen,
they have to share as well,
but there's a double bond between the oxygen.
So it's a lot stronger.
So this hydrogen peroxide is unstable.
Water is very unstable or sorry,
water is a very stable,
so hydrogen peroxide,
unstable water,
stable oxygen,
fairly stable but unstable enough that you can breathe it and live.
And you know,
like we,
we break down oxygen to survive so it's not that stable.
So this reaction generates
fair amount of heat as it goes,
but that doesn't mean that it just happens spontaneously necessarily.
So,
um,
I have a bottle of hydrogen peroxide here,
says 30% on the label.
It's not quite 30%,
it's about 20%.
Now you can kind of see,
it looks like soda.
There are some bubbles on the side of the bottle.
This is just,
it slowly decomposes.
We keep the bottles in the freezer.
So the reaction happens as slowly as possible,
but it's still decomposes.
It releases oxygen slowly.
Um,
you can heat this up to a boil and it will decompose explosively.
You don't want to do that.
Also light can make the reaction go faster.
That's why if you go to the pharmacy and buy a bottle of hydrogen peroxide and
it's in a dark bottle,
it's cause light.
Actually breaks it down.
Now the stuff you get in the pharmacy is about 3%,
maybe 10% if you're using it to bleach your hair.
I don't know if anyone's used peroxide for that.
Uh,
I haven't,
but I've heard it really hurts.
Um,
this is 30%,
which is why I'm wearing gloves,
a lab coat,
safety caucus.
Um,
but basically there are catalysts that will make this reaction go millions or
billions of times faster than it does just at room temperature.
And so I have,
just so you have an idea,
when we're talking about sub stories,
create sub straight geometric amounts.
I have about 10 milligrams of three different catalysts.
So you have a white powder,
yellow powder,
and a black powder.
Yellow powder is iron chloride,
the white powder is sodium iodide.
So we have,
and the black powder is manganese dioxide.
So about 10 milligrams of each of the catalysts.
I'm going to put 15 milliliters or approximately 15 grams of the solution in
each of these flasks.
Now the solution is only about a quarter hydrogen peroxide,
but
it's still several grams of hydrogen peroxide to a 0.01 grams of catalyst.
Here I'm going to add iron chloride to one of these flasks.
Okay.
You can see solution turns dark.
Nothing really is happening now,
you know,
it just looks,
it looks kind of Brown,
maybe some little bit of Fizz in there and see some tiny little bubbles.
So this catalyst actually has a pretty substantial induction period.
So the iron chloride itself is not the catalyst.
It's a pre catalyst and it takes a little while for it to react.
So that guy's going,
we'll check in on in a little bit later.
Sodium iodide.
This one is nice.
We have this white powder.
It's going to dissolve in this clear solution.
Yeah,
instantly it turns yellow.
The actual catalyst is yellow.
And we can see this is actually fizzing pretty substantially.
Manganese dioxide last catalyst should be a little more active than that.
Can See.
It's basically just as soon as we add it,
it's decomposing.
Okay,
so here we have comparison three different catalysts of the same amount.
We have not so good.
Pretty good.
And this is going really fast.
Well,
we could also talk about the,
uh,
you know,
if we increase the amount of catalyst that's in any of these reactions,
we're gonna increase the rate.